last Friday the LCS had a segment on
their broadcast that pissed off a lot of
people it all revolved around perhaps
the biggest controversy we've seen in
League of Legends in the past couple of
years the investigation of TSM Reggie so
what's happened now
all right so many of you may be familiar
with the origins of this story but I'm
going to do a quick recap because it has
been about six months since I last
talked about it way back in November
2021 current hundred thieves 80 carry
doublelift accused his former boss TSM
CEO Reggie of being a bully who made
people cry he's like a bully who gets
away with
being a bad person
because he's powerful because people are
afraid to stand up to him and that's
what I'm sick of so I was to say that he
made a lot of players cry you would be
very [__] surprised at how many of
maybe your your favorite familiar faces
in LCS
legit mental breakdown because of how
badly they've been getting berated how
badly they were just getting verbally
assaulted in January 2022 Wyatt
published their investigation into the
claims and quoted former TSM staff who
said they'd been subjected to mental
abuse by Reggie some said they've been
dominated by a culture of fear in May
TSM shared the results of their own
internal investigation which found there
had been no unlawful conduct from Reggie
no evidence of derogatory comments no
sexual harassment and no marginalizing
or discrimination of women there was
some criticism at the time that some of
what that investigation found Reggie
innocent of wasn't really what he was
being accused of in the first place the
investigation did add though that after
interviewing 31 current and former TSM
staff members they characterized Reddy's
feedback to his employees as having a
harsh and aggressive tone three of those
interviewed told the investigation they
had heard Reggie call employees stupid
trash or worthless and sick
characterized his behavior as creating a
Culture of Fear at TSM riots report on
the matter came in July and stated
clearly that they believe there was a
quote pattern and practice of
disparaging and bullying Behavior
exhibited by din that's Reggie and that
this quote included verbally abusing Pro
players and TSM staff members and
communicating in a demeaning and
belittling manner Riot said Reggie have
breached their rules on both profanity
and hate speech and the forbidding of
harassment they find TSM 75 000 and
required that Reggie take part in a
third-party run sensitivity and
executive training course they also put
him on probation until July 2025 and
threatened severely enhanced penalties
if he's found to have broken the rules
any time before then so that's a pretty
quick summary of everything that
happened up to about six months ago and
since then there's not really been much
talk about it until last week last
Friday was the first time hundred
thieves played TSM in the LCS this
season it was set to be the first time
that double F was going to face off
against his former team TSM since
returning to Pro play and becoming a
pretty public face of the whole ready
controversy the LCS broadcast team ran a
segment in the build-ups of the game
hosted by Le Tigris in which they
covered a lot of what we've discussed in
this video so far but the tone was a lot
more casual people dug up old TSM
content to connect the dots between what
doublelift was seeing and these ancient
logs and streams the sir deal actually
sparked a whole side plot of accusations
investigations and I'm not going down
that rabbit hole but if you want to do
that on your own time by all means point
is there was a major coverage of this
story felt like even your grandma's
hairdresser was talking about it now I'm
not going to play the full three-minute
clip right now but I do encourage you to
watch it for yourself if you want to
form your own opinion now firstly the
segment was supposed to tfwf's history
with TSM but it mentioned almost none of
that really not the LCS titles he'd won
with them not the fact that they'd had
this whole Changing of the Guard not the
fact that he and Bjergsen were now
facing off against TSM together none of
that really but that wasn't actually
what got people riled up for quite a lot
of people out there they just found the
whole thing a bit tone deaf they felt
the segment was mostly using serious
investigations into workplace bullying
to sort of drum up game hype with an
almost meme vibe to it and for a lot of
people it felt especially odd that this
segment was ultimately produced by Riot
but talked in a lighthearted way about
their own investigation and Punishment
of Reggie it just felt like a conflict
of taste all of this is something that
doublelift touched on when he reacted to
the clip after 100 thieves victory over
TSM this is just so weird and the way
that it's presented is so [__] weird
if you really think about it I mean it's
like it's a workplace harassment it's
like legality is involved where there's
actually like lawsuits in people's lives
people's emotional states like this is
like a deeply traumatic uh series of
events that happen to a lot of people
not just me and perhaps for the first
time in two years doublelift and tsm's
management agreed on something that this
segment just didn't feel right although
perhaps for different reasons on TSM
subreddit senior team manager Austin
smack Haggart said he was shocked and
saddened by it that they had a great
team of players who didn't deserve to be
disrespected before an important match
tsm's head of social dunk replied to a
fan in a thread and suggested that a
conversation between tsm's management
and the LCS was well underway perhaps
that worked because on Saturday LCS
commissioner Jackie felling issued a
statement in which she said the segment
was not intended to be disparaging to
TSM but that after further review they
felt it was a miss when it came to
lifting up their teams in a new and
entertaining way and yesterday we had an
official statement from the LCS which
said much the same but also included
double lift in its apology while
emphasizing that they sincerely regret
the negative impact their misstep has
had on Le Tigris matigris herself also
posted a twit longer on Sunday which
began with an apology to anyone at TSM
that was hurt bothered or discomforted
by her monologue she explained that
someone pitched the topic for the
segment that the team thought a
monologue would be a fitting structure
and that it went through multiple
iterations but that in her words it
clearly missed the mark Le Tigris also
added that she'd been horrified by the
harassment and vitriol directed at her
by Anonymous trolls and asked them to
remember that she's only human and not
an object to throw hate at because of a
mistake there was a fair amount of
support for latigris after her apology
including from former and current league
hosts sharks hoped that people would
move on and not continue to Dogpile on
this and that you can only live and
learn fellow LCS Talent Azale praised
latigris's guts for accepting
responsibility but highlighted that was
a responsibility and failure of the
whole LCS team not just hers but one
person that didn't like the apology was
doublelift he replied on Twitter saying
apologize to everyone who experienced
verbal abuse and workplace harassment
then remove the useless straw man where
you still see yourself as the victim and
this might actually resemble an apology
okay now before we dive into all of that
I think some important context to
remember is that doublelift has never
really been the biggest fan of latigris
on the broadcast and that's something he
spoke about in his recent stream I I
have a problem with the way latigris is
a broadcast Talent
and in my opinion not
very good at that but at the same time
the like I said I don't think she's the
one solely responsible for
okay yeah I don't think she's the one
fully responsible for the segment all
right back to double lift's tweet it
seems like he's saying that the
paragraph in latigris is TWiT longer
where she asked people to stop harassing
her over this is her playing the victim
which I don't really think is the case I
think she's apologizing and just asking
people to not harass her for her mistake
that's it I also don't think that that
constitutes a straw man argument in any
way I think on some level doublelift
doesn't like that the twit longer
focuses a lot on TSM as an org and
doesn't really apologize to any of the
people that Riot themselves say were
harassed by Reggie in their
investigation but I guess the question
is is that what latigra should be
addressing within her twit longer
apology look at the end of the day
latigris was the face of a pretty Daft
LCS segment which was produced by a
whole team but somehow she's ended up
with double lift demanding on Twitter
that she apologized to everyone that
Reggie ever harassed or intimidated now
perhaps you have thoughts either way
about double s reply perhaps you agree
with him or disagree with him but either
way it's leading us away from the core
issue of this story ultimately we've had
an apology now from the Tigris and the
LCS that addresses the main problem that
most people had with this segment that
it made light of a pretty serious
situation to Hype up again and I think
in a story as messy and as convoluted as
this one that's as good a place as Annie
to put a pin in this one for now as
always though let me know your thoughts
on all of this and I'll see you all in
the next one
foreign